[موسيقى]
كمان بنلاحظ تحسن بالحاله النفسيه للشخص
خلال فتره شهر رمضان والشهر الفضيل
[موسيقى]
نلاحظ بصير عندهم اعراض يلي بترجع بتتعب
نفسيتهم بيرجع الاكتئاب بيظهر عندهم فينا
نسميها مجازيا اكتئاب ما بعد شهر الفضيل
لذلك نحن دائما بننصح للاشخاص هدول بعد ما
يخلص الشهر الفضيلي حافظوا على خلينا نقول
الروتين والحياه اللي عملوها
بالزيارات المتعدده لافراد العائله الدعم
الاجتماعي والنفس اللي بياخذوه من الاشخاص
العائله يحافظوا على روحانياته اللي عم
تكون موجوده خلال الشهر الفضيل ولذلك نحن
كمان احيانا نتطلع على الاشخاص اللي بيكون
عندهم فقد لحدا عزيز لالهم او بيبتعدوا ما
عندهم دعم عائلي خلال شهر الفضيل لما
يكونوا متوقعين هذا الشيء يكون موجود لما
يكون هذا احيانا حتى بينخفض مزاجهم اذا ما
اخذوا هذا الدعم او حتى اذا ما كانوا
بيرجعوا للروحانيات تبعه لذلك احيانا
بنلاقي احيانا يمكن نفسيته تتعب خلال شهر
الفضيل اذا ما اخذوا هذا الدعم الموجود
لذلك طبعا بننصح شلال الشهر الفضيل الواحد
مع عائلته ويستمر بهذا الشيء ما بعد الشهر
الفضيل
[موسيقى]